archie battersby's family want to spur
him on to recovery but instead they say
the hospital treating him keeps asking
them to give up on him and say goodbye
just totally deflated really quite
upset at the justice system now i've
said before
i don't think
any parent should have to go through
this reform needs to be made and it
needs serious looking at
bart's health nhs trust has been allowed
by a court order to withdraw life
support treatment
when it happens
archie could die within minutes
after three high court trials and two
court of appeal appearances his parents
asked the united nations to intervene
under its convention on the rights of
persons with disabilities
the right to life and the right to
equality
the u.n did intervene asking the uk to
halt withdrawal of treatment while they
consider the case
the uk has signed up to the convention
which means that it should abide by that
injunction but the treaty was never
incorporated into british law so when
the government handed that decision over
to the uk courts the court of appeal
ruled that it can only decide the matter
based on domestic law
the judges said it would be
inappropriate to apply an unincorporated
treaty in a uk court
i've got my son's best interest at heart
and paul and the siblings nobody else
has got archie's best interest at heart
and i say and i still
stand by it
archie's best interest would be to allow
that child time to recover if he doesn't
recover he doesn't recover but give him
time to recover
the family say they'll take this matter
to the supreme court
not for the first time the trust say
they'll prepare to withdraw treatment
after midday tomorrow arch's family will
again be asked to say goodbye sadia
chowdhury sky news in london